yeah yeah i'll keep all this in
that's the start of the video right now
i look all right
oh are we going oh yeah we're good
what is happening there reject nation
greg here and i have my friend
ashley anderson hi guys how's it going
oh yeah
yeah we show ashley's been very busy
lately reason why is come
june what june 20th obviously shot this
a while ago but evil season 2 now
available on paramount plus
and ashley is a series regular on the
show can't say much about it but what
can you say the first season i was
obsessed with i
loved it so then when i got to be on the
second season i was so excited but it's
on uh paramount plus this time
and i play abby who basically
torments uh ben played by ossif he has
to start confronting his
demons no pun intended yeah it was a
super super fun shoot and i'm excited
for
you guys to see it very sincere
anywhere we're gonna watch today 15
painful makeup prosthetic actors were
forced to wear and i figured after
ashley's work on evil and then even
on star trek beyond i'm like ashley
would
probably know a thing or two about i've
worn prosthetics makeup prosthetics
yeah cover her up let's see what's in
store
guys remember evil season two ashley
paid me ten
thousand dollars to tell you guys about
that today yes i'll write you a check
later
oh it's not already in my account
everyone knows actors and actresses deal
with the stress of hair and makeup on
set
but did you ever think that their
on-screen makeup and prosthetics
might be taking a toll on them anyone
who wears makeup knows just how annoying
putting it on and taking it all off
again can be
but wait till you see the painstaking
process that these 15 actors were put
through
in their makeup transformations to make
you feel truly grateful for your own
makeup routine
stick around to see how these actors and
actresses dealt with these sticky
makeovers
after 20 different makeup tests to find
the perfect shade of blue for jennifer
lawrence's character mystique
the process of completing this actress's
makeup for the x-men film
was already proving to be challenging
can you believe it took six girls seven
hours to fully paint the actress's body
every woman knows as our dream come true
in order to keep herself up and adam
during the application process
lawrence would either stand or work out
on a bicycle to keep her blood pumping
not only was lawrence's full blue body
suit of makeup
arduous to get on but it was painful to
keep on
as the actress reported the blue paint
to be irritating to her skin
causing boils and blisters to her
complexion apparently they've simplified
the bluing of you turns out they never
had to do eight hours of full-blown body
paint ever
oh i really get the vibe from jennifer
lawrence that she
is very frustrated with the x-men
franchise just due to that makeup alone
oh really yeah i can't believe that she
was gonna she was riding a
like an exercise bike because they did
it like you'd be like sweating and
they're trying to do the makeup i don't
know how that
how that would work but seven hours is
quite a long
time makeup that i did for natalia on
star trek beyond was seven
hours and then what people also don't
think about too
is that there's a long time of the
taking off process otherwise you're
going to get like you know it's going to
stick to your skin and you're going to
get all these like rashes and stuff so
you have to like
carefully have it all taken off and
that's a couple hours too especially
when you're filming you've got to go in
there earlier you got to stay later
it's been like kind of public with
jennifer lawrence there seems to be like
this tone of resentment in her voice
movies have progressed yeah i wonder why
for that like they didn't do
um a bodysuit you know rather than
actually painting it
on because they're a bunch of dumbass
i'm sure there's pros and cons to all of
it as much as the prosthetics used on
anya chalatra may have added to her role
on the set of the witcher
the very same prosthetics that enhanced
her acting abilities
also caused her physical harm and the
costume and the blood and
the blood after being fitted with a
hunchback to make her character that
much more believable
the star fell victim to a pulled nerve
causing her lots of pain
the thickness of her costume caused even
more sweaty discomfort that the actress
had to deal with during her time on set
she even said i have a trap nerve in my
back that i had to get massaged out
after playing her for so long
it was very uncomfortable not much for
this beast
that's the first time i've ever heard of
someone having like a physical
condition stem from just makeup wow that
movie looked cool i've never heard of it
but i kind of want to see it now it's a
netflix show called the witcher
oh okay yes have you heard of the video
games
no have you heard of the books no then
you should go
watch netflix is the witch i feel like
yeah i have a lot of
research to do i'm sure when they do
like makeup tests you know
because i've been in this position where
it's like you do makeup tests and like
okay cool it feels
great but then you don't really think
about after having worn it for like
12 hours into the day things just start
to hurt you start to feel it all
so i give actors who wear a lot of
makeup a lot of credit because then they
also have to like
act through that as if it's their own
skin and they're not in pain i never
really i never look like that you're
you're wearing weight essentially
totally
yeah oh that's a good point mm-hmm you
know you're
you're a good guest you're a good guest
ashley
from a full-blown head cast to hours of
makeup it's no wonder anne hathaway
needed to vent about her makeup
experience for the witch's movie
she took to instagram and called her
makeup look her resting witch face
after sitting through having her whole
head enveloped in
whatever that is in order to mold her
facial prosthetics
hathaway must have needed to take a
well-deserved breather from her makeup
process
if you notice you know in the length of
the video because it's a time lapse
i got stuck they did all that for her
yeah i i can't i mean i guess that means
the makeup was good if you can't tell
that there's that much makeup on there
but i
can't really tell facial wise what was
added can you no
i was like she looks just like i guess
to put the hair
thing on and off there's probably pieces
that she's wearing so even like when
they did the live cast where they showed
all that blue stuff and they wrapped it
you have to sit with that on for them to
make the mold
so that way when they do pieces they'll
fit perfectly to her face so whether
they use
20 pieces or one piece it's gotta fit so
that's why they get like that exact mold
of your face
but it's crazy because like you have to
go into like a super like
meditative state of mind when you do
that because you can only breathe
through your nose
like you can't that's the only way so
you you're covered in layers and it
starts to get hot and you have to sit in
that for
quite a while and i've had it done to my
body too so it's crazy you have to just
like really mentally like
zen out it's a challenge
i watch youtube videos every day that's
a challenge
[Laughter]
after insisting upon the use of
prosthetics herself angelina jolie was
fitted with cheek
nose ear and teeth prosthetics to bring
her character in maleficent to life you
brought this on yourself
angelina yeah she asked for it to be
somebody that when you were staring at
her during a real dramatic scene
that you were distracted by her makeup
so it had to be extreme but her soul had
to come out
despite its simplicity this makeup look
took a full three hours to apply and one
hour to take off
every day and jolie wore it for 16 hours
at a time
ouch and it was like um living out some
childhood fantasy that's not so bad
angelique
being in such intense makeup for his
role as vision was in no way comfortable
as paul bettany is seen ripping off his
full face makeup
which might be the most painful part
this makeup look takes the actor only an
hour and a half of application time
not too shabby compared to some of the
other actors on this list
the most uncomfortable part of betany's
prosthetic setup is his lack of hearing
with makeup artists having to make
adjustments to his prosthetics in order
for him to be able to hear at
all i didn't think for a minute what
that was actually going to mean to me
physically wow i can't imagine that he's
a real character
in that show and he has to like have
full-on dialogue driven scenes
even right now us talking with these
noise cancers that's how it is
bose and jbl headphones
which you can get using these refer i
don't have referrals
it is weird because you do kind of feel
like you're almost like underwater in a
sense yeah
you feel like you're talking like how i
was saying like i feel like you talk so
loud to people and people have to really
yell things and i've been like doing
scenes where they'll be like move camera
left or do this or do that and like i
don't do it and then they're like
actually but i like i
i like you can't you can't hear
sometimes you know so
you're tired you're fired you don't
listen to anyone
but then the good part about that though
is like when you're in conversation with
somebody you have to
really like focus on them like
emotionally you know what i mean like
this hector's really connected to me
right like really read their expressions
which actually
kind of helps yeah that's true yeah
there's a really cool yeah so there's a
plus to it it's not so much about the
words at that moment it's yeah it's
about the emotion
yeah the hell yeah but what's behind the
eyes ryan reynolds painful makeup
application for his character deadpool
was truly grueling
because of the time that went into the
look reynolds was a good sport
maybe even too good of a sport as he
pranked his makeup artist by ripping off
his facial prosthetics after hours of
application
i'm not gonna do it right you know
there's no point in doing it at all
during genres baby
which left him barely able to see and
made his skin break out in an allergic
reaction oh no
lord of the rings actor had to work on
alternate days in order to give his skin
a break from the harsh makeup process
you can't
really see my brows moving all the rest
of it so have you contracted any
specific diseases while wearing makeup
luckily no i have not i've definitely
gotten like
sore and then i filmed in dubai with the
star trek makeup and dubai was like 100
degrees and we were filming outside
so it was so hot you sweat so much that
i got like you know a few like little
heat blisters but luckily i haven't had
anything too crazy yet this looks like
an intense one he's got a lot of hair
and then he's got to wear a helmet
there's a lot going on here
uh yeah have you seen that movie no
uh oh is that lord of the rings
it's okay if you haven't seen movies you
work on movies
you're too busy doing the actual
creating in order to transform lead
actor jacob tremblay into a boy with the
genetic disorder traitor colin syndrome
makeup artist needed full body
prosthetics to make it work
the makeup itself took an hour and a
half of painfully meticulous application
and suited jacob up in a full head of
prosthetics no way is it comfortable
wearing a fake
face and head for nine whole hours of
shooting
it was like there was a nice cozy warm
cocoon around your head ah
he loved it and that's the door
character design kai alexander's role as
leaf was no exception to this
imaginative creativity
the most painful thing about this
makeover process was definitely its run
time
as kai had to sit for nearly 10 hours
and ready for the spotlight i sat in a
chair for 10 hours
top to bottom including the wig
10 hours that's all record record time
the most complex and interesting of any
of the characters in guardians of the
galaxy
it was very challenging especially on a
female had to be sexy
and uh kind of comic book but believable
this makeup look was so intense you're
female you gotta be sexy
and she even required karen to shave her
head she knew this going into the
audition process
but didn't really get a chance to
process the bald-headed change until she
got the role
i don't know if dedication to a makeup
look gets more uncomfortable than that
and i might have done something a little
bit
oh good crazy her that fact about her
totally i did not know that she didn't
either that's cool it definitely would
make it so much easier for the makeup
artist because doing the bald cap is
like a whole nother thing
so that's awesome that she's that
committed to do it and she looks great
with the shaved head she's on the season
of doctor who that i just made it to and
i was watching her and i was like
damn you know like my main familiarity
with karen gillum is her as nebula
she's actually like this really great
actress and she's also this very
attractive actress
who then gets put under all this makeup
and then i'm noticing
that's what it's like for so many women
and this is this compilation of people
who are just
hidden but then the makeup artists are
like but they still got to be sexy
because they're women well i mean i
think for that particular role too she
was like
no every role every role actually for
all women
yeah who are you playing in evil same
thing happen to you you guys will have
to see
i don't remember what it looks like to
be
i honest being pretty scared when i saw
it so you're right i'm wrong but no
karen gillum shouts out to her
she never even asks good for her cause
like jennifer lawrence she wanted to be
more not
in makeup as much because she hated
doing the makeup and karen gillum in
none of the marvel movies you ever see
karen gilman's only nebula the entire
time that's pretty cool
very cool yeah she's committed this not
very well-known actress
has had an even less well-known
transformation into pepper from american
horror story asylum
the makeup look that transformed her
into pepper takes about three hours and
two makeup artists
including blinding her in one eye with a
contact lens and setting her up with a
pair of fake teeth
imagine sitting in makeup for three
hours and then having to walk around
half blind afterwards
i thought that was a real person when i
watch this
really that's real yeah the most
uncomfortable part of vladimir's
transformation into the night king in
the game of thrones series
has to be the six and a half you heard
me six and a half
hours of sitting in the makeup chair
then once in full night king garb
the actor had to remember not to blink
while in character
the combo of painstaking makeup
application and these intense stage
directions
definitely made for an uncomfortable
experience on the game of thrones set
not to blink easy but
it's definitely not so easy wow
another leading woman who had to deal
with the absolute torture of full body
makeup application
is zoe saldana in her role as gamora in
guardians of the galaxy
just like jlaw she had to deal with the
trials and tribulations of many color
tests to get her to be the perfect shade
of green
the marvel franchise star revealed just
how long it took to apply
all of her makeup over three hours and
with the help of two separate makeup
artists
the whole coming together of gamora
every morning
that was a little grueling famous
actress haley berry played
six different characters
but you may have never even seen it her
makeup transformation into six
different identities was surely an
uncomfortable hassle
as the actress also had to deal with a
recently broken foot on set her makeup
artist jeremy woodhead
is quoted saying even with all the
discomfort she was going through
it was necessary to the story of each
character
that part was thrilling as an actor and
a huge challenge
one of the most known makeup movie jobs
in history
has also been you know i've heard so
many stories about when transforming
into the grinch
jim carrey is known for being irritated
by yellow contacts he's still not seeing
this
have you still not seen this and needing
the help of a torch not all the way
it was when i did the grinch i was uh
literally the makeup was like being
buried alive every day
oh my god sounds so awful
so devastating about how much time and
pain went into their looks
before you judge their acting it might
make you appreciate them that much more
hey they would have done a better job it
wasn't for all the damn makeup they were
wearing man
wow yeah jim carrey seems like he he was
not about that life
when you're younger too like um the kid
who did it who seemed like super
positive about it
there's something about when you're a
kid doing it you think about it less
you know true i did a makeup for star
trek voyager and i was like
i think it was like 10 or 11 or
something super young and that was the
first time i did like full prosthetics
and it's just you don't even think about
it like you don't even think twice about
i think when you get older and you have
like anxieties you start to like
overthink and
you know what i mean you have to go into
like a different like headspace but i
feel like when you're a kid you're just
like oh cool
because he seemed all happy and positive
about it when you're an adult you're in
a rush
i didn't even realize that some of them
were that intense of a makeup
no well guys if you want to see some
great makeup
go watch today's sponsored show evil
june 20th evil is sponsoring this video
they're not they're not now i gotta be
buried and joel harlow is the makeup
artist who
i've worked with tons of times and he's
he's awesome super fun to work with
he owes me five dollars five dollars
add that to my check that i'm i'm paying
you to mention okay
put it on my tab guys thank you for so
much for boehner thank you to the thanks
for putting this video together
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
you can follow ashley on instagram and
more importantly watch evil this is what
happens when you ask
greg to i didn't even ask i offered i
was like come on we'll talk about evil
really quick
i just overdo the same repetitive
sentence watch a vote watch
it do it oh and maybe i'll watch it oh
thank you that might be too busy